9-1-1 calls and police body camera  footage released today and an  officer-involved shooting between  Henderson Police and a 19 year old man  back in October police tell 8 news now  Mark Ellsworth was having a suicidal  mental breakdown and wanted police to  shoot him sometime during all of this  the residents police were called to also  caught on fire now we want to warn you  what you're about to see could be  considered disturbing  mark this is the Henderson Police  Department we want to resolve this  peacefully come out with your hands up  and empty please  Mark please  thank you  well police say Ellsworth was eventually  arrested without injury and no officers  were hurt now there was no press  conference given for this incident and  Henderson Police did not give eight news  now a chance to ask any questions